well it was really a community that I
grew up in you know in terms of my the
culture that was right around me that is
my the people who i would call my
friends and family for the most part
they were colored people and my mother
and father had a big effect on me my
paternal grandfather my maternal
grandmother had a big effect on me there
was a woman next door called miss
Johnson who was actually very large
woman about maybe she weighed about 400
pounds she had a huge effect on me she
was a great storyteller and I used to
ask her to tell me stories all the time
and when kids were out playing well we
didn't have stickball on the street but
our version of softball or baseball in
the back alley I would most likely be
found talking to miss Johnson asking her
to tell me often some of the same
stories over and over again and so I
think that my desire to hear a story
which came from when I was very young is
still with me now and had a huge
influence on me the minister of my
church and his wife had a big effect on
me and then I think the the tougher part
had to do with my schooling and junior
high because the kids in that school
really stayed in groups that had mostly
to do with with race and and social
class so for example even among the
Jewish kids it was really clear to me
they had a certain pecking order and the
the kids whose families had recently
come for example from Eastern Europe
were segregated again away from those
who were more assimilated and that
really bothered me and you know when
something bothers you you can on the one
hand turn it into something which I've
tried to do in my life but there's
another way in which the fact of it the
fact that it never goes away and you
sort of see those saying the
in your own life and certainly we live
in a world that may not be segregated in
the way the parts of this country were
but we live in a very tribal kind of
world now where there seems to be there
seems to be a almost unsurmountable
challenge in terms of how do we soften
those borders and boundaries